a group in Colorado right now say that
the 14th Amendment is sufficient to
remove Trump from the 2024 ballot this
is Citizens for responsibility and
ethics based in Washington DC Group
filed a lawsuit on Wednesday on behalf
of several Colorado voters to keep Trump
off the ballot because here's why
Section 3 of the 14th Amendment says
that public officials are not eligible
to hold office if they quote engaged in
Insurrection or Rebellion against the
United States now
Trump for all of the ridiculous charges
that have been thrown at him in New York
and DC in Georgia and Florida none of
those charges is for insurrection
obviously not it's absurd even if that
were the case I don't see any evidence
that that fact alone would preclude a
man from running for president